these high school students are learning
about a city with a very special history
this is what the entire city was
supposed to look like back when the
planners designed it plenty of green
space and interesting buildings the
valley these apartment blocks were built
in the 1950s in the Stalinist
neoclassical style in Eisen hittin start
the architecture itself is a monument to
history in the model socialist city
industrial workers would live in
spacious green housing estates rather
than dark and crowded urban tenements
it's a perfect example of what were
called palaces for the working man
Eirik VISAA knows that it's the stories
in the history behind the architecture
that makes it so interesting but what
draws people here today is the
relationship between the socialist
ideals of the former East Germany and
the architecture they created after all
isin Hooten star doesn't have anything
spectacular like Cologne Cathedral or
that's finger Palace in Dresden in isin
hidden stash the most spectacular sight
are the steel works
visible halfway across the city the
local museum documents the city as it
was envisioned nearly 60 years ago an
old architectural map in the grand old
city's most familiar to tourists the
central boulevard like this one ends at
the palace gate but here it's the gate
of the factory eyes and hidden star was
originally known as Stalin status and
was renamed in 1961 old video recordings
document the pride of place once held by
the model city
power upon our the digger excavates
fresh soil only recently covered by
mighty pine trees some for a rolling
mill the rest for a new power plant and
here a new smelting furnace the fifth
one the factory was called Eisen Hooten
combi not asked ironworks combined east
for short EK o today it's owned by
ArcelorMittal a global steel company
visitors can take a look behind the
scenes and watch molten iron being
poured into special molds it's heated to
over 1,200 degrees Celsius and then
processed into heart rolled coils the
steel works now employ about 2,500
people only a fraction of what it was in
the former East Germany but the factory
still shapes the city's identity it's an
impressive operation for the visitors to
processing it was fascinating I've never
seen anything like it before I didn't
want to leave a visit to Aizen hittin
start offers many opportunities to learn
about the history of former East Germany
and one of the best ways to understand
it is on a walking tour